[音楽]
今日は
この動画でん
皆様に
お願いがあって動画を撮っています
[音楽]
ああああああ
で花粉症がだ
パンッ
皆様に
お願いごとがあってこの動画を撮っていますどうか
[音楽]
今一度
皆様の力を
お借りすることはできませんでしょうか
[音楽]
では行こうこういったいう出るこれも人によってなんていうのがわかりませんが私は
場面切り替えと呼んでおりますこれはなんかあんまりユーチューバーで使っている方が
居なかった時期から僕使ってるんでワンちゃん僕が発明したのかなとか思いながらもう
決してそんなことはなくテレビとかではよく使われている手法なんですけども場面が
切り替わる時に
どうやってその場面の変化を視聴者見てる方に伝えるかっていう一番分かりやすい方法
は場面が切り替わる間に何かを入れれば
変わったんだなっていう分かりやすく近く的に聴覚的にせるシーンが切り替わったん
だって分かるものが
場面切り替えでございますいつから私は使っているのでしょうか
ぺペンっていう音として出てくる文字02
ちょ mex これは僕が昔で使ってた youtube の id のやつなんで
かなり昔だと思います
もう覚えてませんが多分後6年くらい前でしょうか最初に使った動画皿も覚えてない
くらいかなり昔から使っています
誰かわかったら教えてくださいそれくらい古く使っているこの場面切り替え
はいこれを
パッたらしくしたいねー
あっよろしくお願いというわけですねすいませんあのエンディングレイパー
今日ばいいんですよ皆さん良いものを作ってくださるんです本当にも白いやつもこれで
誰がいつもあのホント
ネットメール味を占めました味をしめましたあの子バターの金取ってる僕も
めちゃくちゃ楽しいし見てるのも凄い技として見れるし
今皆様自宅にいると思うんでひょっとしたらすごい今参加しやすいんじゃないかこれ
ほど場面綺麗でずっと使っててコレハエっていいんじゃないかなって思っちゃいました
このエンディングついでにねに潜入でもすべて賃金一定して
エンディングも買えますしたこの場面切り替えもずっと使っている日本ある方も多いと
思うんですよ
これも変えちゃっていいんじゃないかなと思いましたよ名前も変えようかなというわけ
で今回この動画を撮らせていただいておりますエンディングに引き続き場面切り替えの
動画を
道中いたしますみなさまよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
何ではありません自粛ねぇ暇なちょっとは入りませんやること皆さんあると思いますで
ももう水
暇な方がいらっしゃったりあっ行ってみたいって思ってくださる方がいたらぜひあの
場面切り替え作ってくださいがお待ちしておりますいやこれあのすごい大事なんです
けど結構
気づいたらいろんなやつ ever 間使って場面切り替え場面切り替え大事ですよ
これ
なんか動画の質がうがーっとちょっと見え方乾杯するぐらい大事な一瞬のものだと思っ
てるんで動画っていうのは一瞬のイメージ変わりますから時の場面切り替えの募集を
まず知っておりますと具材できない子を説明していきます
動画の概要欄に応募フォームがありますそちらから
を押してくださいいろんな守る事を書いてあるのでそちらをちゃんと守って応募して
いただけるところでも富士
ている
ございます o 機関が4月いっぱいまで募集します4月の30日まで募集いたします
よろしくお願い致しますねこれですねあの僕がパッド付くっていいものだと思うんです
けどなまっちゃうもんじゃないじゃ多分すごいたりすると思うんでいろんなの僕も見て
みたいして皆さんがどういうのがいいのかなっていうのをちょっと聞いてみてっていう
のはからでぜひともつけてみてくださいで
僕の大体のイメージなんですけども場面切り替えですよね長い動画じゃないんですよ
一瞬のものなんですよ
それに僕の場面9階ピュアな奴は0.5かですで叩けないですよドンドコドンドコ
ドンドコも1秒ぐらいそんぐらい水帰っていいんで炊いたいた文明展5秒から3秒差
じゃないから0.5秒から2秒の動画んだと桜
ってます一瞬音なんですけど一瞬のものほど難しいんですよその2秒にすごいものを
作ろうとしたら時間かかるんですけどもどっちかというとどういうものを作るかって
いうそのアイディアアイデア勝負になると思ってるんで結構な金4月30日まで期間を
撮らせていただきました
なんか僕のイメージなんですけどもたまに実写じゃないほうがいいよね東てます
文字とかイラストとか
すごいな動きのある何かと買う旬で弾み社長っぽい感じが全くそれじゃなくても良いと
思いますもういろんなのなんでも
何でもください後日動画でまた発表会素敵な作品だったら皆さんに紹介したいと思い
ますのでぜひ皆さんの桜も待ちしておりますあの
が病態すっごい評判よくて本当に何か皆様戦で狂って良かったんで今度はもっと店も
一瞬あの場面綺麗な一瞬なんで結構いろんな人が参加できると思いますでたくさんのご
応募お待ちしておりますじゃんっ
[音楽]
bl